I was gonna ask - we're back with go MMO
simulator my favorite game ever came
maybe net bed I really like it
MMO which of course stands for masculine
manned ovary why do I keep saying that
Maskull many Mongolian are orders
yes that's it if let us microwave we
play - rogue we play this hunter now
let's play a certain I want to save the
best for life's baby thank it is oh god
it scares me every time
damn I'm so buff hey girl what's it I'm
so sorry I can't control my strength you
see I never glass we need that for them
the mermaids said two out of ten very
well yes feel free to walk over me I
don't care you've sort of a birch
alright let's see our abilities but I
don't want to hurt anyone so let's go
over here a chart oh I can charge oh my
god oh the nostalgia their nostalgia
okay I can jump oh my god there's no
nacelle yeah I don't know are you
playing a tanking in WoW
I was pretty good I don't want to brag I
have one quest of ANOVA so let's go baby
hey would you get big fight me fight me
is that all you got filthy casuals are
we going to the Elven forest yes yes of
course
Oh an hourglass awesome gimme gimme
gimme and now we're guys of the midnight
show somebody else I think that's the
song 3 out of 10 awesome
damnit I don't swim very well whatever
that movement is I don't do it very well
that's a tank water is my least M&E me
no wait
my worst grass some monsters I decided
to drive the duty extent we have to save
them alright bring them to the Magic
Circle so we have to bring the Dodos got
it I don't know what you guys are doing
but I don't like it damn it damn it
goats not happy not happy goat stop this
nonsense
where's the sugar baby oh there's a
buttered we needed about
yay there we go we got the butter in an
hourglass wonderful set of giraffe
veggie wrap what do you do that's sick
[ __ ] alone yeah I'll bring it with me
forever Jesus let's get [ __ ] up what
the hell is going on here this is not
the Elephant City I came for these are
not the Elvis I'm looking for what that
what what is this what is this I find
something secret
well this out what oh my god I broke the
server no error unknown you have been
signed out from the game no the game
crashed what oh my god what a weird
Easter egg Jesus what happens if I kick
yes the questions of life oh no all this
stuff I grabbed is gone that is bullcrap
does it even make any sense
damn it don't break the servers whatever
you do don't break the servers oops
Jesus so much exp oh my God look at that
ex oh my god I'm leveling up this is
like the final boss of the internet oh
damn damn it damn it damn it
alright what if I could yes god damn it
third time's a charm isn't it alright so
[ __ ] going there then I'm not go it's
like a hole in the haha that's awesome
hey guys what's going on oh my god it's
an elephant party
I love everything party they love a
charming March Wow
yeah they're fine hahaha knock knock
who's there the punch line by about a
ten baby oh god oh god not the vibrating
bookshelf
oh no the legend have told me about the
vibrating bookshelf oh god is destroying
everything run for your life oh my god
it's over I think I just stopped oh
thank god I got it no I'm no no no I'm a
president of the bookshelf
I'm afraid oh god is happening again
stop it stop it you will not have this
world bookshelf you will not all right
we have some quests to do did it intend
to digit it in digit it dude let's kill
the dingos or whatever
are you why sorry guys I have to kill
you that's two dead Dodos very nice oh
don't run for me
come on dota don't run I'm just trying
to kill you come on I only want to
murder you
come on any microwave you can reheat my
takeout hahaha I love the shots man
alright let's go there there we go we've
finished the quest drop animation what
have you done we have once again save
nature from those barbarians you are as
wise as you are beautiful no don't
compliment me I was only doing my job
now let's engage in sexual intercourse
yeah lothario now like it when you touch
me like that Oh Statue going setting our
fuss that's Travis only the true God can
touch it how do I do it yeah bit out oh
god I don't know what's going on
come on come on don't fight me don't
fight me brother
come on saw it I know you want it I
think you have to be the microwave for
this one we have to find out what's up
with that later why would you get
typical Swedish Wow player I got your
[ __ ] butter there you go great now I
have some butter I need some sugar are
you [ __ ] kidding me
are you [ __ ] caring Mac bring Kristen
straw bale oh I get it I get it
haha there you go Chris and Bale Chris
since Bale
there you go now I can ride this back to
meet my parents
in our hometown G ham
well good luck with that you look like
you smoked a [ __ ] are you okay there
Kristin male I would say that's a yes ah
all right let's go through the portal
wait wait we never actually went there
oh my god it's the town that's my
favorite town I spent so many hours here
at swag dude what are you doing here
sweat fight me swag dude I'm the most
swagalicious
that's right right a quest oh this sucks
awesome oops there you go
I wizard greatings young apprentice
I I look at you I see somebody who's
ready and apprentices ready for the
final test
alright you are ready alright you are
ready to be a wizard there is but one
task left
you must gorge yourself upon our sacred
food what is that eat ten chips and
drink ten sodas are you sponsored by
Mountain Dew or something come on
Gandalf it's jammed Oh Kenneth what do
you do together
sigit you see another quest are you yeah
you they go over there you think you can
do me a solid and help me out over here
I was about to inflate my knee but the
button is way over there what jump on it
a bit will you
and okay one three four dude your knee
are you sure about this have you really
thought this through all right there you
go party oh you're welcome have a great
life I love you what a hero that's my
new favorite quest hey can i inflate my
knee - no it's not inflating dammit
somebody please help me out of this
thing alright
oh no no I'm stuck damn it I'm free I'm
free happy you're welcome
I saved you say thank you now where's
that potato chips MSB assembly Doritos I
knew they were here somewhere
oh no ate the bench I need more Doritos
and Mountain Dew come on where are they
dammit I ran out of disk face alright so
we came in here it trapped us and then I
had to fight a little thing and then he
gave us a new quest and now he's sitting
like that on the thing dammit wake up
there you go that's right that's how you
sit you're a king worthy of this throne
and yes you are alright so if we have to
defeat the old goat in the goatman turn
but that's something we have to do in
the next episode I press I've done it
there hope you guys enjoy watching if
you did believe it like I really
appreciate it thank you for watching
birds as always stay awesome right